maintenant ça va être dur pour vous les
habitants qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire
very tough les numériseurs jaurès quoi
oui d'accord interview nul
ah les villes kravitz est ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère est
sous peu d'interviews et old before war
non mais moi j'étais fissa fissa maman
est ce que vous préférez lennon
mccartney et lennon c'était quelqu'un
sait ce qu'il a fait tout seul c'était
quelque chose vous préférez jagger ou
richard s'est hissé de m'embrouiller là
parce que ces journalistes mon numéro de
téléphone que je laisse ici toute
personne vous avez travaillé avec mick
jagger sur son disque solo dans lequel
vous savez quoi
on y peut pas avoir un sens notre numéro
en question suivante si vous aviez le
choix est ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau je pense que je prendrai
la chine elle est inquiète
vous devez partir trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial lenny kravitz est ce
que vous préféreriez partir avec kylie
minogue natalia imbruglia ou vanessa
paradis
vanessa a well as déjà quelqu'un pour
l'instant c'est pas possible sinon toute
petite voix voilà très bien là toutes
les trois est-ce que vous préféreriez
vous réincarner en elvis presley bob
dylan ou eminem terme et bob dylan
la bombe atomique va tomber dans cinq
minutes
vous faites quoi je vais même amour avec
ses deux filles
au caire comme un régime organes du jeu
pour la noble à simuler à tapotage
capotage vous trouvez votre fiancée au
lit avec un homme
qu'est ce que vous faites vous les
rejoignez vous frapper l'homme où vous
pleurez oui oui
allons-y rejoignons les d'accord alors
il est cocu mais sympa qui est sûr très
importante pour vous qui êtes une star
du rock est ce que vous préféreriez
mourir comme otis redding dans un crash
d'avion comme john lennon tué à bout
portant
comme john bonham
étouffé par votre vos mii ou est-ce que
vous préféreriez mourir comme janis
joplin d'une overdose afin qu'à je pense
que la mort de diana s'étaient plus doux
plus oui si vous étiez en vente dans un
sex-shop
que seriez-vous comme objet à nice et la
machine on regarde mais le mot le mot le
plus con en amour pour vous est ce que
c'est
merci merci ce type là oh là là en
risque c'est que je vois est-ce que
c'est merci encore
ou oui oui on disait mais vous qu'est-ce
que vous passez voilà une fille comme ça
c'est ce que j'aime encore
en sixième album